estelle s il ya beaucoup de monde autour
de vous pour cette manifestation anti
masques et vous porter le masque et bien
ils sont eh bien ils sont une grosse
centaine être a rassemblé ici la place
de la nation c'est une première en
france ce rassemblement anti masques et
ce alors que le port du masque que vous
l'avez dit est en train de devenir
obligatoire dans de nombreuses communes
de l'hexagone
des manifestants à qui entendent
dénoncer ce qu'ils appellent une
dictature sanitaire ce sont leurs mots
je propose de les écouter c'est pas ces
paliers primaire puisse c'est pour
contre consommateur au moins sportif je
vois pas pourquoi je mettrais un masque
parce que j'ai confiance en mon immunité
c'est un rassemblement pour les libertés
parce que là ce qui est en jeu c'est la
liberté c'est une liberté
sujet c'est quand même un truc de dingue
je veux dire nous empêche de subvenir à
un besoin vital qui est la respiration
donc là c'est juste pas onu muselle
comme peine des animaux mais c'est une
forme de dressage pour nous faire
accepter des choses à porte qui vont
être beaucoup plus grave
donc moi je le préviens la population de
se révolter contre ce système de
dictature qui est en train de nous ont
pressés mais qui empruntent qui en
retrace le monde entier voilà voilà pour
les revendications alors vous pouvez
peut-être le voir derrière moi ici des
prises de parole sont organisés pour ce
rassemblement statique qui devrait a
duré jusqu'à 18 heures merci est el farj
en direct donc de la place de la nation
à paris qu'ils sont